Speaker 1: Let's go next to Ricky from
Charlotte. Ricky from Charlotte. Welcome
to the program.
Speaker 3:
Hey, David. I just joined the call log, so I
didn't hear the earlier questions, but has anyone
already asked about the defense seminars debate?
Speaker 1: Well, what was brought up? The only
thing that's been brought up so far about
I was Fetterman earlier this week was that
the left just seems to have higher standards
for candidates sometimes to our own deficit.
That that was really the only angle so far.
Speaker 3: Okay. Well, I guess the the main
thing I was getting at was how was trying to
get an idea of how damaging you think this could
be for Fetterman. And I know that, like, it's
probably remains to be seen. I was trying to,
like, look at other campaigns that have had, like,
you know, things that in theory should have been
disastrous. But some candidates still ended up
performing better. Yeah, I don't know if you saw
back in 2018, there was a there's a famous brothel
owner in Nevada who was running for election. He
was like a big friend of Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: I remember that. I don't
remember the guy's name, but I.
Speaker 3: Remember Dennis Hof.
Speaker 1: Dennis Hopper.
Speaker 3: Okay. He died. He died two weeks
before his election. And he still won by like a 2
to 1 margin. Right. And so, you know, I feel like,
you know, dying has got to be like worse than like
just having a speech, like, expressing yourself.
Speaker 1: So here is my sense of this. You're
right. I don't know what the effect is going
to be yet. The the issue what what really is
disappointing about this is Fetterman is not
having a cognitive issue. It was very clear during
the debate he knew Oz's positions on things.
He knew what Oz had said about different things.
He was having an issue converting thoughts into
speech. And it's not as though this would in
any way limit his ability to be a senator. His
doctors have cleared him for full senatorial
duty. And because it's so close, it's a one
point. Right now, with the polling we have,
it's 1.3 points by which Fetterman is winning.
You may end up with Senator Oz because Fetterman
had a stroke. And that's just so disturbing.
Speaker 3: So you think there are
probably some enough undecideds left
that would be willing to flip their vote?
Speaker 1: I'm not saying there are. I'm
not saying there are. But I'm saying it's so
close that even if the number is really small,
it could flip the election. I don't think it's
a large number of people. It's just so close.
Speaker 3: Okay. And I guess the last thing on
this is, what do you think Spiderman could do from
here? Like the last two weeks to turn this around?
Speaker 1: I don't think there's anything. I think
it's just it's the ground game. And I don't I
don't know that Fetterman publicly doing stuff
is what he needs. I think it's just he's got
to have a better ground game, get out the vote,
put on, repeat the fact that Oz said local
politicians should be involved in making decisions
about abortions and hope that that is enough.
Speaker 3: Do you think what if he did like a
press conference with like a physician or
something like that and and he was able
to speak more clearly or the issue was it's.
Speaker 1: Got to go really well. And so he's
got to be sure it's going to go so well that it
will convince people. And I just don't know. I
just don't know. Yeah.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Speaker 1: It's it's a frustrating
situation. I agree with you.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Okay, cool. All right.
Well, thanks for taking my call. All right.
Speaker 1: Thanks very much. There's Ricky from
Charlotte raising a very important questions,
that's for sure. Let's go to Ann in
Wisconsin, another critical state in
this election. And welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Hi. I'm glad that I got through.
Speaker 2: So.
Speaker 3: I am looking
at the macro picture of kind of American politics
right now, and I am kind of scared of the overall,
let's say, Nazi is the Asian. Of the Republican
Party. Mm hmm. And I think you've talked about
it and the increasing anti Semitism. Yes.
That is taking over and from my perspective,
being one of those letters in the LGBT. It is
terrifying because I think what gets overlooked.
Is that the Nazis are the reason that our research
into LGBT health is not where it should be. We are
years and years behind because one of the
pioneers, I believe his name is Hirschfeld,
all of his research was burned by the Nazis. So
and so. And this is relevant because the question
of the Supreme Court overturning gay marriage is
kind of up in the air right now. Yes. And to me,
this just screams, holy shit, we're
going down Nazi land and it's horror.
Speaker 1: It would be better if you didn't
swear, because we have to bleep that. I
also. I did. Did you have a question today, Anne?
Speaker 3: Yes. Yes. Do you have an overall.
Sense that that's the direction. That we're going?
Or do you think that's a fringe? Do you think
that's going to become a majority of the party?
Speaker 1: Majority? I don't know. But it's been
made abundantly clear that they're not stopping
with their victory on Roe v Wade. You don't have
your biggest victory and then say I'm done.
I mean, okay. Michael Jordan retired at the
top after three, but then he came back and he won
some more. And then, you know, the point is it's
they're not going to just call it quits. After
one of their biggest victories in decades, they've
said they believe that the gay marriage decision
was wrongly decided in the same way that they
believe Roe v Wade was wrongly decided. So they're
coming for it. The question is, will they succeed?
And I don't know the answer to that. One thing
that scares me and is that if you look at recent
right wing in-person events, like, for example,
CPAC a few months ago, the biggest applause lines
were the anti LGBT comments. And it happened with
Ted Cruz on pronouns and it happened with Trump.
And so it does seem that there is a resurgence of
anti LGBT sentiment within the Republican Party.
Speaker 3: Right. And my take on that, and I
don't know if you agree, is that none of them
care about that. It's just mass hysteria.
Speaker 1: Who doesn't care about in
what sense? They don't care who wins.
Speaker 3: They don't I don't think they really
care about the gay marriage or the the pronouns.
Speaker 1: Oh, I think they do. But I think they
care about it. More broadly about what
they feel it means for the direction of
the country and less about individual
LGBT people that I would agree with.
Speaker 3: Okay. Because I think I don't know.
I just think are they going to use this kind of.
Rhetoric because I honestly think that
they're going to go Nazi just flat out.
Speaker 1: Well, I don't know. Let's hope that
doesn't happen. But in the in the immediate,
we have some very important votes coming up
just two weeks from now. So I know you'll
be voting and and I really appreciate that.
Speaker 3: All right. Thank you so much for
having me on. Sorry for the sweaters.
Speaker 1: No
problem. There is an area in Wisconsin very,
very important stuff. And I appreciate that.